today on the matt walsh show the biden
administration is explicitly
discriminating against white people and
men as it dulls out coveted relief this
is what systemic racism actually looks
like so we'll talk about that today also
five headlines including trump's
facebook ban is upheld southwest kicks a
three-year-old off a flight because
although he was wearing a mask
they were afraid he might take it off at
some point in the future so they kicked
him off and south carolina brings back
the good old-fashioned firing squad
which i think is a positive development
we'll talk about that plus our daily
cancellation and so much more today on
the matt wall show
[Music]
we've only got a few more days until
mother's day
and let me give you a let me let me try
to bail you out here and give you a
great mother's day gift
suggestion and this is a great gift for
any occasion and a great gift for
yourself as well that is legacy box
legacy box is a super simple mailing
service to have all of your videotapes
camcorder tapes film reels and pictures
uh digitally preserved on a thumb drive
dvd or on the cloud legacy box is a way
for you to easily and affordably
preserve your past if you've got all
those memories stored on those outdated
you know modes of technology
they're collecting dust they might get
damaged you have a flood or and you lose
all that stuff forever it's happened to
many many people
and so use legacy box and here's the
process it's very easy
start to finish
you pack and send all the stuff you want
to have preserved the team digitizes
everything
uh by hand on their end and then they
send the box they send it back to you
and uh that's it
you get back perfectly preserved digital
copies on thumb drive dvd or the cloud
ready to watch and share and enjoy again
this is a perfect gift for mother's day
so for a limited time legacy boxes
running a 50 off mother's day special
order your legacy box today to take
advantage of this incredible offer this
is one of the best discounts they've
ever offered legacy box is perfect for
you or for someone you love go to
legacybox.com walsh and say 50 while
supplies less that's legacybox.comwalsh
it's not as easy as you may think to
find a simple definition of the term
systemic racism given that we hear it so
often wielded with such blithe certainty
you'd be forgiven for assuming that the
phrase actually well
i don't know means something but it
takes some digging to discover what that
meaning is if there is any meaning to
discover at all an article in usa today
published during the height of the blm
riots last summer
appears intent at first on answering the
question the headline says
what is systemic racism here's what it
means and how you can help dismantle it
okay
simple enough the piece surveys various
civil rights leaders and advocates
including the head of the naacp and also
the president of the racial justice
advocacy group race forward
between these authoritative sources the
following definitions of systemic racism
are offered and i'm quoting now
um the complex interaction of culture
policy institutions that holds in place
the outcomes we see in our lives also
systems and structures that have
procedures or processes that
disadvantage african americans and also
systemic racism is naming the process of
white supremacy
okay so to summarize
systems and structures have procedures
and policies which interact with
cultures and institutions to create
outcomes which lead to disadvantages
caused by the process
of white supremacy
well that clears things up
but the ambiguity of course is the point
if systemic racism has no clearly
discernible definition then the
definition could be whatever the
activist needs it to be in any given
moment systemic racism like so many
other terms these days sea
gender whiteness privilege human rights
etc means anything and also everything
and also nothing all at the same time
but if you're not satisfied with the
fluidity of the term and you would like
to settle on something more solid so
that you can actually apply it to the
real world in a meaningful way
then perhaps this definition that i
found from the alberta
civil liberties research center will
suffice this is what they say
systemic racism includes the policies
and practices entrenched in established
institutions which result in the
exclusion or promotion of designated
groups
now this is still wordier and vaguer
than it needs to be and it seems to
dissemble a bit with the with the word
includes
you know but it gets us closer to the
answer all we really need is the last
part with a couple of additional
qualifiers systemic racism if it means
anything
must mean
the explicit and purposeful exclusion or
promotion of designated racial groups
by a powerful institution
that's a coherent and self-contained
definition
which may render it useless to the
racial justice activists but makes it
useful to those of us who are actually
concerned about finding and exposing
true examples of systemic racism in our
society
and there are examples of it on that
note
here's an example that may be worth our
attention breitbart reports quote
restaurants and venues owned by white
men will be last in line for federal
relief under president joe biden's
restaurant's revitalization fund
prioritizing funds for women and
minority groups
as part of biden's american rescue plan
act of 2021 the small business
administration is opening the
application process by which owners of
restaurants bars and other venues can
apply for federal relief to help make up
for the loss of revenue as a result of
economic lockdowns spurred by the
chinese chronovirus chronovirus crisis
the plan allows business owners to apply
for relief of up to 10 million dollars
per business and no more than 5 million
dollars per physical location
business owners do not have to repay the
funds so long as the money is spent by
march of 2023 the relief though is being
prioritized based on race gender and
whether or not business owners are
considered socially and economically
disadvantaged individuals
that's the report from breitbart we can
refer to the
small business administration website to
confirm breitbart's reporting
the website lays out the process and the
timeline for restaurant owners to apply
for relief the first three weeks are
designated the priority period
kind of like priority boarding on
southwest airlines
before you get kicked off for not having
a mask on
and only the priority groups are are
going to be processed and funded
during that priority period
now to discover what qualifies as a
priority group we are told to see below
and you got to scroll down a little bit
and then it clarifies that a priority
group is a small business concern that
is at least 51 percent owned by one or
more individuals who are
women or veterans or socially and
economically disadvantaged
but who counts as socially and
economically disadvantaged once again
we're told to see below so you do a
little bit more scrolling continuing the
goose chase and then we find this
stipulation
socially disadvantaged individuals are
those who have been subjected to racial
or ethnic prejudice or cultural bias
because of their identity as a member of
a group without regard to their
individual qualities
economically disadvantaged individuals
are those socially disadvantaged
individuals whose ability to compete in
the free enterprise system has been
impaired due to diminished capital and
credit opportunities as compared to
others in the same business area who are
not socially disadvantaged
in other words
as long as you're not a white man who
never served in the armed forces you get
to enjoy priority status
white men can go to the back of the line
how is it fair or legal to penalize
business owners for their race and sex
and what in god's name does any of this
have to do with covid
those are questions that you simply are
not supposed to ask
there's no answer for them that they're
going to give you anyway
the small business administration is
being straightforward in its
discrimination against men here
but they're being a bit more coy about
the racial component
so it doesn't actually say anything
about race specifically it doesn't lay
out the races that are included and not
included it doesn't explicitly state
that white people are excluded you need
to read the subtext
but the subtext is written in big bold
blinking letters and uh and so you
really can't miss it
on the other hand
the usc the usda um is handing out its
own coveted relief under biden's
direction
and
that agency is not in the slightest bit
shy about the racial bigotry embedded
into the process
here's a report from cbs
it says a group of midwestern farmers
sued the federal government thursday
alleging
they can't participate in a kova 19 loan
forgiveness program because they're
white
the group of plaintiffs plaintiffs
include farmers from wisconsin minnesota
south dakota and ohio
according to the lawsuit the bite
administration's covet 19 stimulus plan
provides 4 billion to forgive loans for
socially disadvantaged farmers and
ranchers who are
black american indian hispanic alaskan
native asian american or pacific
islander
white farmers aren't eligible amounting
to a violation of the plaintiff's
constitutional rights the lawsuit
contends
yes the lawsuit contends that but again
the agency's website confirms these
contentions
an article on usda.gov
titled faqs on american rescue plan debt
relief for socially disadvantaged
borrowers begins
with this it says earlier this week we
posted important information about the
american rescue plan debt relief
payments for socially disadvantaged
producers
the american rescue plan includes
provisions for usda to pay up to 120
percent of loan balances
as of january 1 2021 for farm service
agency direct and guaranteed farm loans
and farm storage facility loans
and then it says
if you are a black native american
alaskan native asian american or pacific
islander or are of hispanic latino
ethnicity
with one of the loans listed above you
are eligible for the loan payment
all right
so
whites need not apply
they literally need not apply because
you're not going to get it because
you're white
of course the claim that all minority
farmers are socially disadvantaged
and that only minority farmers are
socially disadvantaged is absurd on its
face
one of the plaintiffs joining the
lawsuit um
uh is a man named adam faust okay
he's a disabled cattle farmer with spina
bifida who lost one leg to a farming
accident and the other leg to diabetes
the bite administration offers him no
relief at all
on the basis
that a legless disabled diabetic farmer
has no social disadvantages because his
skin pigment pigmentation is slightly
lighter than some other farmers
this is not only insane and grotesque
but it's out and out racism
systemic racism to be exact
because you have a powerful institution
namely the united states government
the most powerful
excluding one group based explicitly on
their race while elevating other groups
based explicitly on their race
now in our country today
there are no policies or laws none
that expressly and intentionally elevate
white people over racial minorities
you cannot give me one current example
of that
something like this in the reverse
where we've got a government policy that
says
we are
here's an advantage and if you're white
you qualify for it but if you're not you
don't
there are plenty of current examples of
of laws that reserve special privileges
for those who are not white but not for
those who are white
examples of the reverse
and these are just two of the most
recent
so systemic racism yeah it is indeed a
problem in the united states it's just
it's not the sort of systemic racism
that the racial justice activists
want to talk about
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well if you're like me uh and you're a
sedentary lump on a log then you spend a
lot of time sitting down even if you're
not a sedentary level you still spend a
lot of time sitting and that means you
need to think about the kind of chair
you're sitting in
and that means you should consider x
chair extra has you covered for your
office chair needs the secret is not
only their patented dynamic variable
lumbar support which offers unbelievable
lumbar support to your lower back but
now thanks to their
hmt technology you can also get heat and
massage therapy while you're sitting at
your desk um instead of your old
uncomfortable office chair now you can
look forward to spending hours sitting
in their ultimate therapeutic massager i
think i mentioned a few days ago i was
complaining about my
my back aches because that's the kind of
content you get on this show but
um and i i have the uh the x chair right
here and i was enjoying the heating and
massage feature uh and i thought it
would be very helpful so i cannot
recommend it enough x chair is on sale
now for a hundred dollars off go to
xchairwalsh.com now that's the letter x
chairwalsh.com or call one eight four
four four x chair x chair has a 30 day
guarantee of complete comfort and you
can finance your purchase for as little
as 30 bucks a month go to
xchairwalsh.com now use code x wheels
for free x wheel blade casters as well
again that's exchairwalsh.com
all right so uh you know i my wife and
kids are away for a few days visiting my
uh my sister-in-law and that means i was
on my own last night and you know and
you know me you know what that means
okay
things are about to get pretty
crazy especially down here nashville
nightlife
let me forget about it it was it was
party time to put it lightly
so basically i ended up watching a
documentary about volcanoes and then i
fell asleep um
and it was uh that was it was really a
pleasant evening actually and see that's
the thing when you're married and you
have kids and then you get a night to
yourself
at first you always get that sort of
like tinge of mischievous excitement
similar to how you felt when you were 17
and your parents made the cataclysmic
mistake of leaving you alone for a
weekend
and you you feel that way for a second
and then you and then you you say to
yourself oh yeah never mind i'm old and
boring i forgot
it's all quite sad really but um
the documentary was interesting uh
warner herzog into the inferno if you're
looking for documentary volcanoes i
would recommend that one all right this
is uh from reuters it says facebook
incorporated oversight board on
wednesday upheld the company's
suspension of former u.s president
donald trump but said the company was
wrong to make the suspension indefinite
and gave it six months to determine a
proportionate response
trump called the decision and his
banning across tech platforms a total
disgrace and said the companies would
pay a political price
um
and uh
so he's he's still banned at least for
six months
and trump is upset about that and says
they're gonna pay a price right well
first of all the two things here it it
obviously is absurd
to ban
the former president um
from any social media platform
especially all of them as he currently
is
it's absurd it's it's it's
uh
dangerous it's pretty
terrifying the kind of power these
platforms have
to have to have effectively
erased a former president he leaves
office and he's gone
um and that's why they're doing it
and i think i think everyone knows that
even if they won't admit it this is this
is obviously politically motivated
and they don't want to give him the
platform back especially if he's
thinking about running again in 2024 um
because
and they also don't want to be blamed
by the media there's a thing if if
facebook and twitter let donald trump
back on
and then he runs in 2024 and wins
they're gonna get blamed for that
by by the sorts of people that they
don't want blaming them for things
so the whole thing is is totally wrong
however
you know the reason why i can't
generate a lot of anger and outrage over
this
to the same degree as other
conservatives and other and other you
know conservatives and media especially
very very upset about the trump facebook
ban and all of that
i can't get myself to feel all that
upset about it because as i have argued
many times
trump had the chance to do something to
rein in big tech and he didn't do
anything
or even try
and so now
he he's he's here he is impotent and
powerless
hanging out at mar-a-lago
promising that they're gonna pay a price
no they're not gonna pay a price
actually
you have no power
right now none doesn't matter what you
say
you could have made them pay a price
when you were the president of the
united states
republicans could have done something
when they controlled the entire
government with trump at the top of it
for two years
they didn't do anything
nothing what do they do during those two
years when they control the whole
government what do they do about big
tech did they do anything
nothing no
not just about big tech they didn't do
anything about anything
they just didn't do it they passed a tax
cut
that's what they did
well done fellas great job gave us a tax
cut
and uh that was it
with republican control of congress for
two years and then republican control
the white house for four years
what do we get at the end of it we get
uh tax cuts
and then some other policies uh all of
which have been were erased by the biden
administration like that
gone
as far as making
making a lasting impact doing something
big and important
and difficult
like reigning in big tech for example
didn't even try
they talked about it
republicans are talking about it again
now when they have no power to do it
that's that's that is the republican
move it's to wait until you have no
power and then to start talking a big
game about all these things ah let me
add them
if yeah let you know it's it is it's
like
it's like the the kid in high school
or middle school
you know who starts talking a big game
in class
acting like he wants to fight another
kid when the teacher is right there and
he knows the teacher is going to stop
him
and then you find that kid outside of
the classroom like at the bus stop and
he's he's running for the hills
that's what the republican party is
that's what they are
they talk a big game they become big
tough fighters and warriors when they
know they can't do a damn thing anyway
because they got the teacher in the
class that's going to stop them
put them in charge of the class they
actually have some authority now
and uh they become pushovers
biding their time until they have no
authority again
so yeah i'm not i'm not in the mood to
cry any tears for any of them
this is what happens
you fed the alligator and then it ate
you like
that's that's that's how that goes
all right
here's something that
does provoke um my anger this is a story
from nine news in denver i want to play
the local news report
and it's worth bringing to your
attention i'm actually hesitant to bring
it to your attention a little bit
because i may have trouble refraining
from screaming obscenities
at the conclusion of this clip so i'll
try my best
but let's let's give it a listen
traveling anywhere with a family has
always been tough but traveling these
days is even tougher the cdc says
everyone aged two and up has to wear a
mask on board a plane at all times orion
can you say hi three-year-old orion
scott does pretty well with it
especially when you consider how
difficult it might be for him my son has
sensory processing disorder which means
that sometimes he gets overwhelmed by
different sensations like touch texture
his mom caroline says sometimes the mask
can be too much it's why she's got a
doctor's note saying he might have a
problem with his mask but mom and dad
know how to handle it it's why she
called southwest's customer service
department ahead of the family's flight
on a dia to visit orion's 94 year old
great grandma in florida she was told
everything would be fine when we
actually got to our flight
we were told
that there was an issue and they had to
ask the supervisor to ask the captain's
permission for us to board all this time
his mother says orion was doing fine
wearing the mask seat belt buckle came
onto the plane and said that we needed
to de-plane because the captain did not
feel comfortable with my son on the
plane and that was it she says they were
removed from the flight simply because
she took that precaution to warn the
airline about what might happen we were
trying to do the right thing and we were
punished for it the family spent nearly
two thousand dollars booking new flights
on a different airline for the next day
she says orion was fine on that flight
in a statement today southwest told us
they regret the inconvenience on the
family and that customer service was
reaching out to them
hold on i'm cycling through all the
things i can't say right now
landing on something i can say um
yeah okay
i told you we shouldn't have played that
this just makes me so angry it is it
infuriates me
in such a deep and visceral way
to treat people that way to treat kids
that way especially
he kicked him off the flight he was
obeying the rules that this the stupid
useless um
rules that there's no reason for those
rules to be in place in the first place
especially for a child
that the kid already poses basically no
risk to anyone
as it is and everybody else on the
flight by the way like children
as we've said a million times
low-risk group you really don't have to
worry about them
statistically speaking in terms of
coping but also
everyone else on the flight if you're an
adult you're wearing your mask
and we're at the point now in america
where most people you know in in for
most regions of of the country
if you wanted to get the vaccine
you've probably gotten it by now
so anyone on that flight who really
wanted a vaccine
probably has it
um the people who haven't had the
vaccine yet for the most part are people
who you know
either they don't want it or they're a
little more hesitant about it or they're
not that or they're just not that eager
for whatever reason
so if you're an adult
worried about covid
uh you wear your mask you got your
vaccine
what it's even more of a reason why the
hell does this kid need to wear a mask
for your sake
but then on top of it he's obeying the
rules
the stupid oppressive
rules he's obeying them
and you kick him off the flight
out of the the fear that he might
not obey them in the future
because he's a three-year-old with
sensory processing issues
talk about discrimination
i mean i hope yeah yeah i'm sure
southwest is reaching out
you know they're going to offer a
you know they'll also offer a rebate or
something and they'll give you
you know a couple of free flights in the
future
uh that's not gonna be enough
this family should own that airline when
this lawsuit is done
this is a blatant case of discrimination
and there's no way that's legal
there is no way that it's legal for for
a for a company
to refuse service to a child on the
basis that he's a child with sensory
processing issues and so uh you're
worried about what he might do and he
might not follow the rules at some point
in your uh
in the future
is there's no way that's legal
so i hope she i hope
this is what needs to happen these kinds
of rules need to fight them in the
courts
take southwest to the court
sue them for all their worth
there's no defending this
all right um
and i and i really hope that captain is
is fired and that's not something that i
say very often i don't often call for
people to lose their jobs but uh this is
someone
i don't know anything about the person
they may have
served the company with distinction for
years for all i know but they should be
fired for that
that is unforgivable
um all right let's move to
let's see liz cheney um
sorry i just really don't care about
this story at all i had this liz cheney
thing to talk about and i don't care
at all so we'll move to this instead
from from cnn it says the south carolina
house of representatives passed a bill
wednesday that allows for firing squads
to carry out death penalty sentences
and makes it like electricity elect
electrocution that's what
i can't speak um a more likely means of
execution electrician it makes
electrician
uh the potential change in south
carolina law comes as states nationwide
have hit barriers executing those on
death row
due to problems administering lethal
injections the widely preferred method
in the u.s difficulties finding the
required drugs have essentially paused
executions in many states including
south carolina which has not had an
execution since 2011.
and now with the uh the bill
they're
gonna allow firing squad that's gonna be
like the default option
but then you also have that you have
that option and also electron
as i like to put it
you know i think this is a good bill um
and
the firing squad is
far more efficient
and i also think it's far more
humane and it's not just a matter of
it's sufficient and it's more cost
effective right because when we're
dealing with something like execution
that shouldn't be the primary concern
um
but i think it's far more humane and
dignified than lethal injection
because the whole point of lethal
injection
the reason why we've been doing it that
way
for so many years
is just to make us feel better that's
really what it's about it's not about
the person being executed
we didn't we didn't shift over from
firing squad hanging you know those
kinds of methods to lethal injection for
the sake of the
it's all for society
so that we can feel better about it
and it feels a little bit less like a
person is being killed
did we talk about medicalization i was
talking about the medicalization
of anxiety yesterday this problem of
medicalizing things well
uh with lethal injection we sort of
medicalized the process of execution
you put them down in a gurney you have
the you know you have the the needle
there
and it's just to kind of sanitize it and
medicalize it and again make us
make us feel like someone isn't being
executed but they are
someone is being killed
it's
it's a it's a a messy
difficult thing
we're taking a life away
and i support it i support the death
penalty i think it's necessary it's a
necessary tool for society to have
but um you are killing someone
and i think we should have to face that
and firing squad is you know it's quick
and i i would imagine it's as it's as
painless as an execution method can
possibly be but most importantly it
doesn't hide
from what it is and doesn't allow us to
hide from what it is
so i think that makes a lot of sense all
right here's something that doesn't make
sense number four mayor bowser at dc has
banned dancing in a move
straight out of footloose or really out
of my own campaign platform when i run
for dictator of the world
but here she is you know i i i'm banning
i i ban dancing
in in principle because i'm opposed to
dancing in principle as a theocratic
fascist uh i certainly wouldn't ban it
for the reasons that she gives but here
she is justifying her dancing ban
on cnn let's listen
i want to ask you about your new
guidelines um for reopening dc it's
getting a lot of attention um here's
what you're saying beginning may 1st
multi-purpose facilities and menus may
host events such as weddings provided
that there may be no more than 25
capacity in any room or up to 250 people
here's what's getting a lot of attention
standing and dancing receptions are not
allowed
what good is a wedding without dancing
mayor and why no dancing
well i think there's a lot of good to a
wedding like people starting off their
their lives together and doing it in a
safe way
and not doing it in a way that puts
themselves or their guests in danger and
let me be clear on may 1st we were proud
of our residents and businesses who made
conditions in d.c such that we can start
opening up these facilities an alternate
headline may be now you can host a
wedding
in washington d.c a regional meeting
you can have your friends and family for
a family reunion and birthday parties at
our hotels and restaurants and just like
our restaurant guidelines suggests is
that you have to be uh seated to enjoy
the restaurant
um i see that i see that um we'll give
you a minute for your earpiece there
thank you
thank you your eminence thank you you're
allowing you're you're allowing your
subjects to have a wedding
thank you so much we bow before you in
gratitude
empress empress bowser
for your magnatomy you are so generous
empress bowser
that's what she's saying she said well
you bet you better be at least i'm
letting you get married
you're little brats you should be
grateful
i'm letting you get married i'll let you
have a regional meeting
a regional meeting
not just a local meeting but regional
the entire region is invited
i'll even let you have a family
reunion as long as you're masked and uh
maintaining social distances but other
than that you could have a family
reunion
make sure the infants and newborns are
wearing masks now of course
speaking of which i'll let you have a
baby in our city as well just make sure
you put that mask on the baby as soon as
it emerges from the birth canal safety
first
you know she never explains and isn't
asked to explain
um how exactly or rather why
um the dancing ban was put in place at
weddings
that question
is not insisted that she answered that
question which that would seem to be
like the number one question when it
comes to this issue we would want
answered
why exactly did you ban dancing
you know all she says is that uh well we
want to have weddings
and we want to do it in a way that's
safe and is not gonna put your guests in
danger okay explain to me
how dancing puts your guests in danger
it puts them in danger of being
embarrassed
like myself if i'm dragged to the
dancing dance floor uh it puts me in
danger it's like a sort of a social
danger of of intense embarrassment which
is why i'm in favor of banning dancing
for for that reason
but what you mean it puts them in in
like some sort of medical danger how
how does dancing spread coven can you
explain that empress
now she can't explain it
she's not asked to explain it they never
are
seems like a fair question
like lay out the
the process exactly
someone dances
so step one
someone dances
step three
everyone in the room dies of covid what
happens in step two you've skipped over
something i need to know what happens
there how did you get from one to three
here
she was pressed a little bit more um
lightly and she said that she's still
given given more
actually she's pressed on
whether
she would allow dancing in the future
even after everyone is vaccinated and
she still wouldn't commit even then uh
let's listen to that
is there dancing allowed in new mexico
governor
well i'll tell you what if you're
socially distanced and you're wearing a
mask and you meet the other
requirements with our level of
vaccinations um yes
right and so i want to give the mayor uh
it takes courage to be really clear
about what constitutes high risk
activities and behaviors and it is
something that democratic governors are
leaving in this country evidence-based i
i hear you but but mayor just just is
there any way that you would reconsider
with masks on and say a a card that
shows fully vaccinated that you'd allow
dancing
we're absolutely considering opening
more activity
as our case rates go down and our
vaccination rates go up and that's in
our hotels
and that's in our other venues
understood mayor bowser governor lujan
grisham thank you very much for covering
all of these topics with us great to see
you
why did i choose all of the most
infuriating
video clips to play in one show i'm
gonna have an aneurysm i'm gonna have a
heart attack right here in front of all
of you
we are actually listening to
governors and mayors
talk about whether people in their
states and cities should be allowed to
dance
that's what we're talking about here
that's what's happening in the united
states of america circa 2021
even if people are wearing a mask
and they present a card showing they're
fully vaccinated
empress bowser says
they still can't necessarily dance
and then the other woman there
on the panel gives bowser credit says it
it takes courage to be clear about what
behavior constitutes high-risk
activities
how is she being clear she's not being
clear at all
oh but at least the other woman what was
it the new mexico governor
in her generosity she will allow you to
dance as long as you're masked and
socially
masked socially distanced dancing
i mean you might as well not have any
dancing at all
i cannot how absolutely creepy it must
that look i want to see what that even
looks like
if any if any um
you know any any people
who are so
cowed and submissive that they would
listen to these requ to these uh
edicts when they
have a wedding reception because of
course the right thing to do
by the way if you're having a wedding
reception in dc is to ignore this
completely and do what you're going to
do and let her send the goons in
to break up your wedding and start
arresting people for dancing let her do
that
force her to do that
force her to send people into a wedding
reception and arrest and cite them for
dancing
but those who are uh actually pathetic
enough to listen to this
if they're you know in new mexico i i
want to i would like to see what that
looks like
just because i haven't had the aneurysm
quite quite yet and i wanna i wanna be
pushed over the edge what does it look
like
socially distanced masked dancing
you gotta present your vaccine card on
your way up to the dance floor there's a
there's a bouncer standing there
present your card
and then you maybe there's like hula
hoops on the ground and you have to
dance within them
you know you each have your little
circle where you can dance
i don't know if they if they prescribe
specific dance moves you're allowed to
do
and not do because certain dance moves
might spread coven more than others
twerking for example
i'm not sure if that's a high risk or
low risk dancing activity i don't know
you know these are we need to get then
we need to get fouchy in here to talk
about that tell us
can you twerk
um
and not spread covet or will that spread
covered
good lord in heaven
we were once a great nation you know
that
it's shocking to realize but we were
once a great nation
all right let's move now to uh
i actually have other headlines i just
gotta i gotta move on to reading the
comments um
if i have them here yes i do erica says
i was diagnosed with an anxiety disorder
in high school now i see that my anxiety
was not irrational but a natural
reaction to the cesspool that public
schools are
my body and mind were responding to
being indoctrinated yeah and you raise a
really important point because
you know so
as i said yesterday it's 50 million
adults have been diagnosed with mental
disorders
uh like once that amounts to one in five
and then it's one in six or one in seven
children have been diagnosed
um
and we're pushing towards 20 million
they were 17 or 18 million children have
been diagnosed with mental disorders and
a great many of them are of course in
public school and it's their experience
in public school um their lack of of
their inability to acclimate or to
thrive in that context of public school
that leads to them being diagnosed as
mentally disordered
which is outrageous and horrific that
we're doing that to kids
because yeah
public school is a very
specific and tailored sort of
environment
that is not suited for all kids in fact
lots of kids naturally will not
acclimate to it and will not thrive in
it they won't thrive in it academically
and they won't thrive in it socially
you're really the exception as a child
if you do
most kids struggle
and rather than
considering whether there's a problem
with the system itself and with the
environment and with the way we're
approaching education instead we say oh
no if kids don't don't do well in this
environment clearly they're diseased
so let's put them on pills
another comment says matt for what it's
worth i agree with your stance on
anxiety and your comments on mental
disorders there is now a mental disorder
called oppositional defiance disorder so
it is now considered a mental disorder
if one has a child or teen who is angry
defiant and argues a lot
apparently the experts who came up with
this have never been apparent i suspect
there will be an oppositional chore
disorder to be declared in the near
future as well
yeah oppositional defiance that's why i
say
300 mental disorders listed in the dsm
it might be more than that now i think
it was a dsm-4 that had 300 and now it's
dsm-5 so um but about 300 mental
disorders listed
and so many of them are
things like this oppositional defiant
disorder
so a child who's defiant and opposes his
parents authority
is has a disorder and of course we'll be
told
like we're told with all of these things
that
no it's yes it's it's normal for kids to
be defiant sometimes but
um there's an imaginary line that we've
drawn here
and uh if the kids are defiant beyond
that line
so defiance on this side of the line is
okay in natural but if they're too
defiant if they cross that defiance line
now it's a disorder
who decides that who decides where the
line is drawn why should we listen to
whoever drew that line that line
more
questions that are that are not answered
jose herrera says
hey matt are you a fan of avocados
i am indeed a very pro
we are we are pro avocado in my
household
we fly uh
avocado pride flag very very very open
to avocados
um truth seeker says honestly in regards
to the child being paddled i think this
punishment should should be normalized
again
um lord that brought back memories for
me i was paddled religiously k through
eighth grade granted i was born in 82
spare the rod spoil the child
but that's why i distinguish between
corporal punishment
spanking
in the home and at school and i think
those are two talk about environments
those are two very different
environments and contexts
if you want to use corporal punishment
as a parent that's one thing
but it is simply a power and a tool that
i wouldn't entrust to the government
school system i'm not giving government
employees the authority to strike my
child to hit my child that's i do not
trust them with that authority i don't
know about you
i don't
joe wright says matt is showing that
he's just a liberal
he was that's me all right such a
liberal
everything i say right
um he was raised in a big city with a
liberal mindset
and i wasn't raised in a big city but
okay i come from small town america
where you could whip any kid you see
misbehaving it didn't matter if they
were your kid or not and if you found
out that your kid was whipped by another
parent when you gave them well then you
gave them another whipping because you
know they deserve it
yeah big city walsh that's me big city
liberal
you know
i got my hate my hair's dyed pink
usually i i
if it weren't for the show it'd be dyed
pink
big time liberal everyone knows that
about me
uh yeah no let me just say
if you assault my child
if you lay a hand on my child then i'm
going to lay my hands on you
that's going to be my
my attitude
if i if my kid comes home and tells me
that another adult in the neighborhood
hit him
i'm gonna find that adult and i'm gonna
hit you harder
that's the way that's gonna go
that's not a liberal mindset okay that
is a father's mindset i'm a father
the idea that you'd let just any old
creepy stranger lay hands on your child
that's insane
what could a parent would do that
you say to they but oh yeah hey here's
my kid any of you want to hit him go
ahead it's fine
do you see how crazy that is
do you
if that's the way things were growing up
for you it was wrong and it was crazy
and if that's the attitude your parents
had it was a bad attitude
really bad
i'm old-fashioned in a lot of things but
i will say that just because things were
done a certain way a long time ago that
doesn't automatically make them better
so if this was the way things were
growing up for you then you were being
neglected and abused i hate to tell you
um so that's something you might want to
work through but but no i do not grant
permission to any stranger to just walk
up and hit my kid you do that there's
going to be serious consequences that
you're going to pay
and um
finally
oh yeah so
a couple of but we played that
clip yesterday of uh juror number 52
brandon mitchell and when he was being
interviewed and he was revealing how he
uh ended up on on the jury he wanted to
be on the jury because it was a historic
moment and he wanted to push for social
change and then of course we find out
that he was attending blm rallies and
george floyd t-shirts and everything
but a few commenters pointed out
like dt barnes here leaves a comment
that says did he call the other jurors a
cast
like a cast of actors
and i did notice that and i forgot to
mention it when we played the clip
in the interview
brandon mitchell is talking about the
other jurors
and i'm pretty sure that's what i heard
too he actually calls them the cast
like cast members in a play
very revealing about his attitude um
and perhaps the attitude of the other
jurors although we haven't heard from
them yet you know because you hear us
constantly bragging about it that uh the
daily wire is growing and we're very
excited about its growth um and that's
only going to continue into the future
uh we you know we have the movie deal
with gino chrono we we have the talk
show talk show hosted by candace owens
we released our first feature film run
hide fight plenty more to come and we
want to make sure that we include you in
our future plans every day in my show i
talk about a lot of amazing products and
services from sponsors that i love and
use but we want to get to know you
better so we can choose our sponsors
with you and mine so please go to
dailywire.comwalsh
and fill out my audience survey tell us
a little bit about yourself and to
sweeten the pot you're going to be
eligible to win a 1 000 gift card if you
complete the survey but uh you only get
eligible one time per survey uh you can
only search complete survey once and and
be eligible once per show that is so
that means you can listen to bench
apparel michael knowles androclavin get
access to their surveys take their
surveys as well and you get entered
again for that gift card again my survey
link is dailywire.com
walsh
and uh listen if you haven't already
joined daily wire you should hurry up
because today is the absolute last
chance to get 25 off a new membership
with code candace at dailywire.com
subscribe if you missed tuesday's
episode of candace don't worry the full
interview with president donald trump is
available for daily wire members they
cover everything from the media's impact
on the president's family to the
likelihood of a trump owens ticket in
2024. if you want to watch that and all
the other
great content that dailywire has to
offer for subscribers today is your last
chance dailywire.com subscribe code
candice
now let's get to our daily cancellation
today our daily cancellation refers back
to yesterday's cancellation though we
will not rehash that subject yesterday
in this segment
we discussed anxiety disorder and i
explained
why i believe that anxiety disorder is a
category error um i don't think that
anxiety is a disorder or a mental
illness just as i don't think that adhd
is a disorder it says i'm already
pissing people off i might as well tell
you that i also don't think that
depression is a mental illness or
disorder
i think that a great many of the things
which we have decided to call mental
disorders actually don't belong under
that umbrella as i argued we are
medicalizing and diseaseifying yes i'm
making that word up fine
normal if painful and difficult aspects
of the human condition and the human
experience anxiety is an essential facet
of being human it's a fundamental aspect
of consciousness it comes with being a
conscious being
it comes with a territory it's not an
illness and we shouldn't call it that
which isn't to say that those who
struggle with it shouldn't seek help or
should be dismissed far from it my
argument actually empathizes with the
people struggling with anxiety i would
argue that calling them mentally ill is
what creates stigma
that is what is isolating
and it does that unnecessarily as
anxiety is not a sickness except in the
philosophical or spiritual sense that
someone like kierkegaard would have
described it
that was the argument for yesterday and
you can go back and listen to that
segment if you want to hear me flesh it
out in excruciatingly long detail
today i'd like to address and of course
cancel
the most common response i've heard to
that argument
and it's worth addressing because this
is the most common response you'll hear
to almost any argument you make on
almost any subject these days
people have been conditioned to react a
certain way to ideas that they find
objectionable or discomforting
the response paraphrased goes like this
well matt you're only saying that
because you've never experienced anxiety
like i have
if you only had my experience you'd be
saying something totally different
anyone who's had my personal experiences
which are so much more profound and
enlightening than your experiences would
of course come to all the same
conclusions as me
that's the basic paraphrase
uh just for fun i'll give some real
examples of this quote-unquote argument
from my twitter and youtube comments
probably not necessary because you know
what i'm talking about but here are a
few anyway
uh one
there's varying forms of anxiety matt
just because you live your perfect
comfortable cookie-cutter life doesn't
mean everyone else has the same
privilege
two i literally have moments where i
have to repeat things to get anxious
thoughts out of my head i've been
struggling with panic attacks and
anxiety my entire life you're lucky you
haven't had to deal with anxiety
disorders because they're hell please
educate yourself
three sounds like you don't have a lot
of experience with the human condition
being covered with privilege will do
that
four i'd challenge matt to live a day in
my shoes and then spew this bs
five this piece of s has never known
anyone with debilitating panic attacks
and it shows but hey he knows about the
human condition so he's more qualified
than doctors apparently
and six man f you eat my entire
you clearly don't live with an anxiety
disorder you ableist effing pile of dog
s
okay you get the idea
as i said hundreds of people have
responded to me just like that and
you'll hear a version of this response
to nearly any topic or any argument you
make on any topic
the person who counters in this way is
doing three things right
first
he is
making completely baseless assumptions
about your personal experience
based on the point of view that you've
expressed second he's declaring that his
own personal experience grants him
special authority that automatically
supersedes your own and third for good
measure he's using emotional blackmail
to shut down the conversation he's
presenting his own victimhood as sort of
a trump card
it's the old my life is harder than
yours which means i'm right but even if
it's but even if i'm not right how dare
you say that i'm not right given that my
life is so hard already tactic
so here's what i'll say to all of that
and i'm addressing this now directly to
all of those who have used this strategy
in response to me or in response to
anyone
to begin with
you have no idea
what i have experienced
you have you assume that i have not had
experiences like yours because your mind
is so shallow and narrow that you can't
even conceive of the possibility that a
person might have similar experiences
and yet draw different conclusions from
it
you're also a narcissist so you assume
that your struggles are harder than
everyone else's struggles and your pain
is so much deeper than everybody else's
pains and your and your life is more
complex and dramatic than everybody
else's life
all of that might be true
but it's probably not
most likely your struggles are about on
par with most people in the modern world
which isn't which isn't to say that
you've experienced no pain
life is pain as the saying goes but you
hold yours up like a trophy
and you brag of its immensity and
complexity
and that's what makes me suspect
that it's not all you crack it up to be
as a general rule people who really
suffer
don't use their suffering to win
arguments on twitter
but all of this is really beside the
point
we're talking about a general issue
see
we're not talking about you
specifically
believe it or not
not every conversation is about you
in fact almost every conversation that
has ever been had on this planet or ever
will be had has not been about you and
will not be about you you are irrelevant
to almost everything that has ever been
said by anyone
same goes for me same goes for any
individual person it's a tough pill to
swallow but it'll do you good
in this case we're having a mostly
philosophical conversation we're
debating the nature of anxiety and of
the human condition and we're trying to
figure out what the word disorder really
means and how and whether a thought
process can be properly called
disordered
you're perfectly free to disagree with
my take on all these questions i might
be totally wrong i realize i'm in the
minority here i realize that almost the
entire psychiatric industry is on the
other side of this issue i realize that
most doctors on the other side of this
issue i realize that most people in
general are on the other side of this
issue
that's fine
i'm happy to hear your argument if i
didn't want to hear opposing views i
wouldn't be saying stuff like this out
loud
so i'm happy to hear any counter
argument especially ones that make me
question my assumptions
those are interesting those are exciting
i actually like it
when someone presents a counter argument
to me that makes me go wait a second
was i wrong about everything i just said
i like that i think that's fun
but
if you're only able to engage in this
conversation through a mixture of straw
man fallacies and emotionally
manipulative personal anecdotes
then i would ask you to sit this one out
in fact i would say can you sit out
every conversation until you learn how
to have a conversation that doesn't
revolve around your own self-obsession
because you're boring me
and you are the kind of person who makes
it impossible for people to have
interesting thoughtful productive
dialogues in this country
because in every conversation anytime
anyone makes any
principled generalized point
here you come in riding on your your
horse
saying what about me here's my anecdote
well this doesn't apply to me personally
let me tell you all about me and what
i've been through
not relevant
you're ruining the conversation
please stop
also you're canceled so there's that too
we will leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pavel vadasky the show is edited
by sasha tolmachov our audio is mixed by
mike coromina hair makeup is done by
nikka geneva and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matte
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. a kentucky
man pulls a gun on blm thugs as they
attempt to disrupt his dinner facebook
doubles down on its censorship of donald
trump and the u.s population continues
to die for that hopeful happy show head
on over to the michael knowles show
[Music]